NICK BUTCHER: --at Google.
And my job is really to work
with people making Android apps
to help them make the
best possible app.
I'm going to talk to you a
little bit about Android today.
I've been given
20 minutes, which
is pretty lean to talk
about a subject which
I could wax lyrical
about all day long.
So I decided to condense it
down to talking about thinking
outside on two topics which I
think are really key to making
an amazing mobile experience--
making an awesome Android
application.
This is two things which I
think people aren't thinking
about enough or not
really understanding,
that if you bear in mind when
you're designing and building
your application, you can
build an awesome Android
application that's going to take
you to next level and go crazy.
I'm going to focus on
thinking outside the screen
and thinking outside the app.
And I'll take you
through what that means.
Starting thinking about screens.
When people look at the Android
landscape or the devices
out there, they sometimes
have this whoa moment.
There's all these
different devices
you might have seen-- scary
charts saying that there's
all these different resolutions.
So people seem to tend
to latch onto resolution.
They understand this number.
This is how many pixels
there are on a screen.
But what I'm going to
encourage you to do
is to throw that number away.
Just don't think about it all.
And instead, think about
the size and density.
So if you think about a screen,
if you consider the size,
like the physical size--
this is a five-inch screen,
this is a seven-inch
screen-- and density,
then you can actually
forget about resolution.
All the same information
that resolution conveys
can be thought about in
these two orthogonal things.
And if you do that,
then Android gives you
really, really powerful
tools to dealing with that.
The first thing is this
little guy called the DIP.
This is what we call a
Density Independent Pixel.
It's a way of abstracting away
the density of the screen.
What it is, as the
line there says,
it's an unit of
measure that keeps
things the same physical
size across different density
screens.
So what that means is, if I have
this tablet on the left, which
is what we call a
medium-density device,
and I size an element
to be 200 DIPs say,
it's going to perhaps use 200
physical pixels to show that.
On a much higher-density
device, what
we call an extra-high
density device,
it might actually use
400 physical pixels
to show the same thing.
But as you see, they'll
be the same size.
So the power of this is,
you forget about density.
You can just forget about
it and size stuff, saying,
I need this to be this big.
I need this to be
this much room to show
an image or this much room
to show a block of text.
And you can abstract
away from it.
Another example of
why this is powerful
is if you have
these two tablets,
on the left this is like a Zoom
that came out a couple of years
ago, which had this
resolution of 1,280 by 800.
And then a year
later, another tablet
with this crazy, much
bigger resolution.
And you might think
oh, crap, how's
my app going to work or
scale onto this screen?
But if you sized everything
in these DIP units,
it actually works out.
Because this one's a
much higher density.
They're exactly the
same resolution in DIPs.
So if you designed
the layout for one,
it's just going to work
on this other device,
even though you had no idea
about this screen resolution
when you designed for it.
What's more, all developers
out there want units in DIPs.
This is the easiest
way that they
can code all the light layouts.
Here's an example.
I think from the
YouTube application
or from a Google
app, where you can
see we're using DIPs everywhere
to size how much space should
things take up, the paddings,
and margins, text size, and so
on-- all in these kind
of abstracted units.
So that's thinking
about size in DIPs.
Another thing I told you
to think about is density.
And the only time you
want to think about that
is when you have bitmap assets.
So when you supply an icon
for example, it needs to be,
when you're in
Photoshop or whatever
use to create your
bitmap assets,
you need to be a certain size.
So this is where you have
to think about density.
So if you have an
icon which is going
to take up 32-by-32
bits for example,
then you want to provide
different sized assets
so that they show,
so they stay crisp.
So they don't get, you're
not blowing up an asset
and it gets will
blurry and horrible.
So this is the
only time you want
to think about densities, when
you're doing bitmap assets.
So when you think about
the two orthogonally,
your life is going
to be much easier.
So yeah, that's the
takeaway message.
Think about size and
density separately.
The opacity is not coming
out from the projector,
but the slides will be available
for your downloading pleasure
later on.
And so yeah, think about
density asset crispness,
and think about size for layout.
And you'll be happy.
An example of this is how
it can future proof you.
So on the left, we have
a high-density phone.
And then in the middle, we have
a large, medium-density tablet.
So if you designed, if you
provided assets for the phone
and you've done the layout for
the tablet, at some later date,
a new device comes
out that you've never
even thought of or
considered, and it
has the same density as
the phone, the same size
as the tablet,
and it just works.
Because you've thought about
these two things orthogonally.
You don't have to
think about what
devices are coming
in the future.
It's going to pick up the right
assets and layouts for you.
And this brings me on to the
subject of responsive design.
So I think Android's learned a
lot from web-inspired layouts--
things like liquid
layouts and so on.
And they get you so far--
having things scaled,
taking up proportional
amounts of the screen
will get you so far.
But I think as the
web world has learned,
the onset to this
plethora of form factors
out there really is to
really embrace the variety
and respond to it.
Yeah, a lot of people
look at this landscape
and they think, how do I do I
deal with all of this stuff?
And so the responsive
design approach
has taught us to think
about break points,
think about step changes,
where your layouts break
and where you need to change
to a different representation.
So you might do
something like this.
You might say, organize devices
into small, medium, and large,
and have different layouts that
work for those different sized
screens.
And the cool thing is
that Android gives you
tools to do this.
It's embraced this in
its very foundations.
So here we look.
I've used these little
crazy looking identifiers
at the bottom to divide
these buckets up.
You have a look at one
of those-- sw600dp.
DP again, for those paying
attention, is the DIP unit.
And what that little
phrase says is the smallest
width that this layout
is going to work on
is if there's 600 DPs.
So you can use
this as a boundary.
If the device has
400 DPs of width,
then you'll use a
different layout.
If it has 600, then it's going
to pick a different layout.
So using these
boundary points, you
can construct different layouts.
And the device will
just pick the right one,
depending on how
big or small it is.
I've also listed out,
there's a bunch of different
what we call resource
qualifies, which
you can use to create
these boundary points.
You can have different layout
in landscape or portrait,
or depending it it's
a different height,
or if it's a TV rather
than a phone, and so on.
Android gives you the
flexibility to do this.
So to walk you through
a simple example
of how you might do that, if you
want to do this master detail
view, this is an example
that my team made,
somehow like meat
news or bacon news.
Which, I don't know, if
you went down that well
when I presented this in
Israel-- the bacon news reader.
Carrying on.
So say you want to do
this master detail.
On a phone, you have
these two screens.
On a tablet, you have
them both at once.
So easy on Android.
Basically, you just define
one activity for the home.
An activity is a
screen basically.
And then on the tablet,
there's a SW qualify guy
that I talked about.
By defining when it is at
least 720 DIPs in width,
and use this alternative layout.
And this alternative layout.
Will just put them
both together rather
than just showing one time.
So you can keep it DRY.
You can be declarative about it.
Very, very easy to handle
these different scenarios.
The next I'll
encourage you to do
is thinking about
these break points
is to start with your content.
Quite a lot of people will
get caught up in saying,
I'm going to design
my tablet layout now.
And they'll say, OK, so
a tablet is this big.
Therefore, I need to
design this layout.
What the problem
with that approach
is, is if someone comes out
with a slightly smaller device--
something in between what
you've thought about-- then
you're stuck.
You have to end up tweaking
these things all of the time.
I would encourage
you instead, when
you're thinking about
these break points,
is to start with your content--
what's in the application.
And then, work out how
much space that needs.
So say you could have
that example there.
I could lay it out either
as two separate screens
or is it a dual-column layout.
I would start with the
content and work out
how much space I need
for a dual-column layout
and then set that break
point based on the content,
not based oh, I've got a tablet.
I want a dual column
on the tablet,
and the tablet is this big.
Doing that means you'll
be happy in the future
when new devices
come up and pop up
in between that you
hadn't thought about.
If you size it to your
content, you'll be happy.
A few quick examples of
doing good just response
design on Android-- share a
couple from the Google suite.
So this is a Google
Play Music application.
As you can see, as we
go to larger devices,
it really easily just
rearranges the same content.
So things get bigger or get
restacked next to each other.
So this is like using
those break points
to say, oh, I need at least
so many pixels of width
or DIPs of width in order to
do this horizontal layout.
Otherwise, if it's smaller,
go into this vertical layout.
Within items as well, if you
see here, this row of cards,
you see, we're changing how much
crop, how many cards are shown,
how much information
it shows in each one.
Very, very simple stuff.
Just by using these same
break points I talked about,
you can just
optimize the content
to respond to the amount
of space available.
So again, simple stuff.
Here's the Calendar application.
Sometimes it doesn't come
out particularly well
on the projector, but
basically, we just introduce
margins when you get
over a certain point.
If you didn't do
something, you can just
let the content stretch
all the way across.
It'll be a pretty
uncomfortable experience.
So you can do some really,
really simple stuff
to make your application
just so much easier
to use for your users.
OK, setting maximum widths.
OK.
There's a great job.
So it changes up from a list,
to a grid, to a staggered grid
as you get more
[INAUDIBLE] space.
Again, very easy to do.
Etsy did a fantastic job
with this staggered grid,
which they've open-sourced.
I've put the links to
that if you're interested.
Cool.
That was a million miles
an hour through thinking
about the screen,
outside the screen.
The second topic
I want to focus on
is thinking about
outside the app.
So it's just really
embracing what
you can do in Android to make
an amazing, immersive experience
that's different to
the web or something.
And to illustrate
that, I'm going
to take you through just a quick
video of a journey on my Home
screen.
So here I am.
I'm on my Home screen--
well, on my device.
And I can already see content.
There's widgets and so on.
And this is the Home
screen on my phone.
If you're not an Android user,
this might look strange to you.
But Android users can
customize and show
widgets and a huge amount
of personalization.
So here, I decided to
just move a widget.
This is my web bookmarks--
move it up to the top.
And I decided to carry
on a search, which
I saved to my bookmarks,
which is pubs in London.
So there they are.
So I click that.
And if you notice anything
interesting there,
so I clicked on a map
and an app opened.
Some people think
URLs don't open apps,
but on Android they can.
So here I am.
So now in a map,
the web browsers
have this full
multi-touch gestural
3D building type
experience, and I
can find a pub I
was looking for.
And I decide I want to
share that with someone.
So I could either use the
built-in sharing, or just
[INAUDIBLE] right there.
I just use the keys to take a
screenshot, and there it is.
You can see, it gives me a
little notification saying,
hey, there's a screen
shot just saved for you.
And if I swipe
down from the top,
I get the list of notifications.
I can quickly, I don't
need those emails.
And I can quickly
use a simple gesture
to expand out that screenshot
I just took, hit Share.
And I want to share
this with my friends.
I'm going to use Google+.
And blah, blah, blah.
So Google+ pops up
a little dialogue,
and I can type in a quick
message, and hit Share.
So that was a really
simple kind of interaction.
But I think the most important
and interesting thing
about that is never once
did I launch an app, per se.
I didn't go to the
Home screen of tiles,
and click into a tile,
and do something, and then
create a screen shot,
and then go into Home,
and then go into
another app, and then
pull in that screen
shot, and then share it.
The whole thing was just
one continuous flow,
based on what I
was wanting to do.
I like to think about this.
A lot of people say
the word "open."
And Android is open,
and it has a lot
of meaning depending
how you take it.
I like to think of
Android being open as it's
open for making more
interesting applications.
And I like to think of
that as a task-based flow.
So rather than being
an app-based flow,
where everyone's going into
your app, and then back Home,
and out, and then
into another app.
And there's these
little silos of data
that never talk to each other.
Android lets you build
these incredible flows
that work together.
So I went between
the Home screen,
and the Maps application,
and Google+ applications
seamlessly.
I wasn't thinking about which
application I was using.
I was thinking about
the task that I
was trying achieve-- find a
pub, share it to a friend.
And you can build these
seamless experiences
really easy on Android.
The other thing
I think is really
interesting about
Android is it's
open for innovation, which
should be interesting for you
guys.
Because at any point,
you can replace
the default way of
doing something.
So what I mean is, Android
has a built-in text
messaging app or dialer.
But if you have a cool
idea about replacing that,
you can replace that.
You can plug into these
different task flows
that people are trying to do.
It's incredibly
open and flexible.
And it's all available to you.
So I'm going to be a bit
more technical now and talk
about intents.
Intents are the glue that
make this all possible.
As I said, they're the glue
between application components.
And what's interesting
is, they allow
you to do this thing I like to
refer to as outsourcing tasks
to other apps.
To walk you through what
that means, to break it down,
intent is basically a
combination of both an action
and a piece of data-- view
this URL or edit this contract.
And what's more
is, they can result
in a return piece of data.
So when you write
an application,
you can tell the phone
these are the intents which
I know how to handle.
For example, if I wanted
to share a piece of text,
like I love gamma frames, every
single app on the system says,
hey, I know how to
share a piece of text
will appear in that share box.
So when I shared that image
from Maps, the options that
popped up from every app I had
installed on the phone which
said hey, I know how
to share an image.
So by using the system to
be this bus, to outsource
these tasks, you
can plug-in your app
into other people's flows.
So here are a few more
examples of how this works.
Say you have an application.
And in your app, you want to
scan barcodes for some reason
and to link the real
and virtual world.
But you don't
actually want to have
to build the barcode scanning
application yourself.
Instead, what you can
do is you can just
start an intent saying, there's
a well-known intent out there
with an action of
scanning barcodes.
So you just invoke that.
And the system will say, hey,
you have this app installed
which knows how to do that.
It will launch that
other application.
It'll perform the
task, read a barcode,
and then it returns
it back to you.
So you outsource that task
to another application.
Or you can write an
application and offer
an API almost the same.
These are the intents I support.
And other people can invoke you.
Another example is
picking a contact.
You might want to pick a
contact from the address book,
but you don't want to have to
write all that code to do it.
The contacts book, or your
address book on your phone,
already knows how to do
picking contact type stuff.
So you just fire off
an intent saying, hey,
does anyone know how
to pick me a contact.
The contacts app says yep,
I can do that for you,
picks a contact,
returns it back to you.
You didn't have to
write any code to that.
It's great.
And another example, this is how
the Maps example worked early
on, is that your
app can declare it
can handle certain kind of
URL schemas, as it were.
So when I clicked on that
picture of a map and it opened
in the Maps application, that's
because the Maps app had said
hey, any URL which looks like
maps.google.com/whatever,
give that to me.
I know how to handle that.
And the user can pick, do
you want to use the browser
or do you want to
use this Maps app.
And you can set a default
and all that good stuff.
But this is really powerful.
This means if in
your marketing, you
want to send out a
URL to your service,
and you don't have to
have your special thing,
like if you have
the app installed,
then click here or
otherwise click here.
You can just send out
a normal restful URL.
And if they don't have the
app installed, fine, whatever.
It goes off to the browser.
If they do have
the app installed,
you get into this
richer experience.
It lets you build these
really great experiences
for the users.
And the last thing
I want to talk about
is on this [INAUDIBLE]
the app is notification.
Notifications is an incredibly
powerful thing, I think.
And it's always been
very rich on Android.
You can have these large
style notifications,
I like to call them.
So you either have
a standard one
or these-- I'm going to
take you through some
of the more powerful ones.
So we have these different
standard layouts,
where you can have even
larger amounts of text,
show an image in there, have
a completely custom layout.
So there's an example of
the music layer, which
you can control
completely without having
to go into the application.
You can just do pause, play,
fast forward, and so on.
And I think almost
more interesting,
you can have these actions.
You saw when I shared
that screen shot earlier.
I just went to the notification,
hit Share straight from there.
I didn't have to go
into the application.
I just used the
notification as a shortcut.
And what this does is, it
lets you get your app out
of the way.
You don't have to
launch the application.
You can offer some functionality
and complete it very,
very quickly.
So you're a ticketing
app or something.
You could say, new ticket
for this band you like.
Just hit Buy straightaway
from the notification.
Having these actual
notifications
is incredibly powerful.
It's also one of
these with great power
comes great responsibility.
People are getting a bit spammed
out by some notifications.
So here's some
guidelines about when
is a good time to
show a notification.
If it's time sensitive,
your calendar appointment
is in 10 minutes.
Or another person, like you
have a WhatsApp from your wife,
or she specifically
requested it.
These are good examples of
times to show a notification.
If in doubt, probably err
on the side of caution,
because you don't
want spam the users.
Or be smart about it,
like show a notification
and track whether
they responded to it.
If the user didn't respond, then
perhaps back off your strategy.
Or if they did respond,
and they're liking it,
maybe ramp it up.
Be a bit smart about it.
Android has this notion
of priority as well.
So you can say that an incoming
call is much more high priority
than there's traffic on your
[INAUDIBLE] home, or something
like that.
So if you indicate the
priority to Android
of your notification, then it'll
use that to kind of rank them.
So it will give you the
most priority ones higher
and will also display
them slightly differently.
So if you, interestingly,
use this one,
this minimum
priority, what we call
it an opportunistic
notification,
then we won't even show an
icon at the top of the phone.
But if you go into
the notification tray,
then we'll show it there.
It's an interesting thing.
So use this smartly.
Let's get on.
And so you might have seen
the Android Wear announcement.
I think this is an
example of the power
of those actionable
notifications.
The Android Wear platform
is built entirely
on the notifications API.
So these things that show up
as notification on your phone,
they have actions.
And they come out as
quickly actionable things
on your wrist.
So if you think
about it, you can
build an application very easy.
It shows notifications.
It's going to show
up on my wrist.
And I can quickly
action it saying,
tickets have just come
out for a band I want.
Buy it.
Done.
Very, very powerful stuff.
And so I want to finish up just
giving you a few examples which
I think really
embody this thinking
outside the app principle
I'm talking about-- building
applications, which work
with other people [INAUDIBLE]
think about them.
So SwiftKey, I hope you know,
is an awesome keyboard, only
possible in Android, that you
can replace one of these system
components.
Because Android is open, you
can just completely say yeah,
there's a keyboard
that comes with it,
but here's one that
I think's better.
Aviate, which I think
Twitter just bought recently,
is a home screen replacement.
So it smartly recommends apps
to you based on where you are,
and what time of day, and what
apps might be relevant to you
there.
Again, only possible
because you can completely
replace a component in Android.
Has anyone heard of
this Link Bubble?
It's quite cool.
This is a browser which came
out quite recently which
lets you do like tab
browsing as it were.
So here I am in
my Twitter stream.
And I'm clicking on
just standard links.
And instead of popping up
and being one app at a time,
they just open up in
these little bubbles,
letting me carry on.
So when I'm on my
train commute which
has no signal through
Wimbledon, I can just
keep on opening up all the
links in the Twitter feed,
and they open in like
tabs, as it were.
And then I can just
when they're loaded,
I can just read
them when I want.
Really, really cool.
And this is all because of
this intent-based system
that you can do all of this.
And the last one-- oh
no, there's one more.
Bolt again, is a pretty
innovative dialer.
It replaces your
standard dialer.
But if your friend's
using Bolt, then it'll
use VOiP rather than PSTN, so
you get free calling to them.
And it's just
really, really smart.
Again, only possible because you
can replace a system component
and do all this good stuff.
And lastly, one more favorite
app from my colleagues.
It's called Myseu, which
is a wallpaper application.
It will show you a wallpaper,
a different wallpaper a day.
But one of the cool
things about it
is, it offers a plug-in API so
that different applications can
supply different images which
you can set as your wallpaper.
Again because of this
inter-app communication stuff,
this is really, really cool.
You can just install
this and then
other applications
can offer up sources.
So if you have a Flickr
application installed,
it could offer you
photos from Flickr
to show up in your
wallpaper, because
of this inter-app stuff.
So there's just a
few quick examples
to inspire you with stuff
that you can build on Android.
I'm going to end up the
talk with a couple of plugs.
First off, if you remember
one URL from this talk,
go to developer-- or "d",
save you a few keystrokes--
android.com/design.
And this will give you all
of our US patents and so on.
It's a really,
really awesome site.
And my favorite thing about
it is, it's quite small.
So you can actually read the
whole thing in about an hour,
and really get going
on Android design.
If you are interested in
designing for Android,
I do a monthly
now YouTube show--
about a half an
hour show, called
"Android Design
in Action," where
we talk about different
Android design topics.
Check it out.
And that's me.
And this is this talk.
So I think they're going
to be distributed later.
But if you want to
get it now, you can.
Thanks very much.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Thanks, Nick.